il résiste évasif je pense qu'on va
faire une interview confession
alors tu vas te coucher à kedar ce soir
comme d'habitude minuit une mineure est
la messe demain tu as pensé oh oui oui
le texte est prêt quand tu passes à la
télé oui c'est pour dieu ou c'est pour
toi toujours pour dieu dis donc ça
marche
l'islam en ce moment c'est quoi leur
truc bah c'est de mélanger jeu qu'on l'a
fait trop longtemps nous la politique et
la religion à part le vin de messe tu
prends quoi comme drogue un peu de
champagne quand tu mon offre
manger les religieuses d'un droit oui
mais je ne pense à au paradis des
centres et que les baskets on sera pieds
nus si bien plus confortable on sera à
poil ce serait quoi pour toi le onzième
commandement ne fume pas de pétards mais
le pétain sais pas il ya pire que le
pétain mais oui il y avait un père ya ce
vieux incertaine conneries alors on
était juste savoir tu me rassures toi
toujours que moi j'ai vu des vidéos des
fous de dieu complètement allumé un mois
j'ai vu des témoins de jéhovah quand
même pas vu l'accident
pour finir
la pêche